how to get comfortable in front of the
camera I got a great question from one
of my new loyal YouTube viewers is
watching all my stuff Kevin who wrote in
to say that he wants to start doing his
own thing in front of the camera and
he's nervous and he doesn't know how I
do it and he speaks to people all day
but he can't imagine doing it in front
of the camera where he's got nobody to
talk to and it's just him in the camera
and how do you get started how do you
get comfortable in front of the camera
so I've got a few tips for you Kevin
that will hopefully help you launch your
YouTube career the first one is practice
it takes a lot of practice when I first
started I sucked on camera I sucked and
I had done TV gigs before I had done a
lot of presentations before but there's
something about being one-on-one in the
camera that I don't know I just sucked
it was terrible it took me it took me
the whole day to do one video and it was
a crappy video but it would just that
took me that long now I sit down and I
can do 10 to 15 videos in one sitting
because of the practice but I've done a
thousand videos literally a thousand
videos is how many I've done that I've
recorded and posted so it's crazy it's
just a lot of work and you get more
comfortable with it just like everything
else you learn something and you're
trying to pick it up it takes you a long
time to get going and then you get
better and better and better and better
and I find when you're creating
something new you may have really good
taste right you may be able to watch
your video and say I love that video you
know Evans video that's great or I love
that Les Brown video or et video or
whatever it is and then you look at what
you make and you realize that it's it's
crap you know it's just it's not good
enough and there's this huge gap between
what you know is good and what you can
create and that's frustrating and that's
where a lot of people will quit but by
pushing through and by making more and
more and getting better you start to get
better where where you know what's good
and you're slowly getting towards that
and your tastes are generally much
higher than everybody else's my first
videos I look at them with horror
I want to take them down look the look
oh my god what that was that was so bad
and anyway I'm my own worst critic right
you're going to be your own worst critic
people still watch those videos they
have thousands of views they still leave
comments and say what a great video
thank you so much and I'm thinking are
you kidding me I was such a bad video
you know the content may have been great
but my delivery and the it's just it was
brutal in my view and now I'm at the
point where I start to enjoy watching my
videos I'm almost almost closed that gap
between what I think is good and what
I'm delivering so I'm getting close it
just takes a ton of work and practice
and you get more comfortable with it
when I very first started doing it I had
to be alone in the room I couldn't have
anybody with me I had to do it by myself
but there's somebody else I'd be worried
that they would be judging me watching
me when I did them with my DSLR camera
it wasn't autofocus so I had to have my
sister or a staff member focus on me and
then out and then press record and have
them leave the room it's ok be by myself
doing it because I get flustered and
nervous with them and I slowly got
better now it doesn't matter people
could be in the room as long as I'm not
making noise I don't care but it just
comes with a lot of practice so you'll
get there but just start and know that
even though your first videos suck and
even though you try to make them as good
as possible they will still suck that's
ok they will get better with time and
with practice don't get down on yourself
and quit the second thing that really
helped me was a caffeine and sugar I
found that when I first started doing
the videos they were pretty boring and
I'd look at them with a wow I'm about to
fall asleep what's happened in this
video and so I started going out and
getting like the venti Frappuccino super
sugar caramel caffeine to the max and I
would I would drink it just before
filming and and in between my videos and
you'll give me more energy so I might
come off as a bit of a spaz on the
camera I stopped having to do that
because I felt you know what I don't I
don't need anymore I'm
I'm I don't know comfortable enough
getting my energy level high to be able
to speak to you guys I'm excited about
what I'm doing but took me a while to
get there same thing for my radio show
and same thing if I was doing some
speaking before I might down this huge
drink or something just to give me some
more energy so to do that that's okay it
gives you your energy it's not super bad
for you
and they'll improve the quality of
product to a point and then the third
thing I found that really helped is I
try to look in the camera and not just
see my reflection of my face there but I
try to look at the person who I'm
talking to
I try to think of somebody who I'm
talking to and visualize that that they
are in front of me so with a youtube
comment like this it's pretty easy so
when you sent in your comment this
little picture of you when I say oh
that's Kevin so I'm talking to Kevin he
looks pretty Chili's got a big smile on
and so I'm I'm thinking of you while I'm
talking to the camera if I'm just trying
to make a point in general about
something that I believe in that's
important frunch Mirza learn about I'll
try to think of somebody who I have in
mind who who I may have told that same
story to when their reaction I try to
visualize them in front of me so I'm not
talking to the camera I'm trying to talk
to a person and I felt that really
helped and then I guess my last tip is
just remember that it doesn't have to be
perfect you know if you make a mistake
this isn't live you can cut it you can
do it again you could try it again and
try it again and try it again so if you
make a mistake it's not the end of the
world but what's important that you get
started and you practice and you get
better and you're passionate about it
and you continue on you do that you'll
eventually be successful and let me know
if you launch your channel you launch
your first video send it to me I'd be
happy to check it out give you some
feedback I'm excited to see it and don't
worry if you think it's crap because
you're on your path and that's important
journey that you've started believe for
those you watching you like the video
please give it a thumbs up below let me
know what you think leave a comment ask
a question I'll give it a response and
if you want to see more videos like this
subscribe to the channel by clicking on
my face
thank you so much and I'll see you soon
you